The word brexit has become a synonym for
apocalypse for most of media,
at least the media outside of the UK.
There are many things to be said about
this,
but today we're going to focus on this
Goldman Sachs to move hundreds of its
staff out of London,
and this is just one example,
but at the time we're making this video,
20 banks have already announced that
they will move part of their staff out
of the UK.
The most optimistic estimations claimed
that the city of London might lose over
30,000 workers and the most pessimistic
argue that this could be as high as
$200,000.
But wait just a minute here.
Why is this important?
Well,
if you've been following visual politic
for a while,
you already know that London is the
global financial capital.
More specifically that global financial
capital would be the city of London,
also known as the square mile.
Square mile is essentially a city inside
of a city where most of the
international banks have their
headquarters.
Yes.
Even after Brexit,
it is possible that London will keep it
sway on the markets in Asia and even
America,
but so far European business accounts
for 35 percent of the city's workloads
and of course leaving the European Union
is going to have some consequences.
While now you might be wondering,
well,
why are these banks going to go?
Which city will be the new financial
capital after London?
Well,
often monster competition.
It does seem as if we do finally have
winner
and other companies plan expansion in
Frankfurt after brexit.
So far this is a Frankfurt is going to
become the new financial powerhouse in
Europe and perhaps one of the most
important in the entire world,
but what does Frankfurt's sap that other
cities like Madrid or Paris don't?
Well today we are going to answer this
question,
but before we do,
let's look back at the history.
Why are banks leaving the city?
The city of London is an area of about a
square mile.
See where the name comes from,
which is located inside broader London.
They have their own laws.
They have their own mayor.
They even have their own police.
Little bit
base is the home for the main
international banks.
Three hundred thousand people work here
and have this 300,000,
60,000 European immigrants who entered
the country thanks to being part of the
European Union
and okay,
my countrymen,
I know where you're thinking.
Despite being an EU country,
the UK never was really insight.
The free circulation area.
This means that theoretically the
British government could have closed the
borders to all those immigrants sit
anytime they want it,
but in practice,
European citizens we're getting in and
out of the country as they pleased.
It's clear that EU migration to the UK
has increased significantly over the
last two decades.
In Twenty 15,
they were just over 3 million people
living in the UK.
You were born in other EU countries and
increase of about one point 9 million
since 2003.
Nevertheless,
things they are getting exchanged for
the questions to the prime minister,
he British Prime Minister,
conservative Theresa may hold,
holds an extremely weak
position.
This is despite the fact that she won
the general election in June,
she just lost a large number of seats in
the parliament doing that.
In fact,
it's not even clear if she's going to
finish that time.
Of course,
people from in and out of their party,
they are pushing her to increase
immigration controls.
I've consistently said that the
referendum vote was a vote for us to
change that freedom of movement with a
vote for us to bring control into our
immigration system for people coming
from the European Union.
There's a variety of ways in which that
can be done.
This would have a big impact in the city
of London.
Indeed,
a bigger impacts than anywhere else in
the UK.
As we said in another video.
Positive London success comes from their
ability to attract talent from all over
the wells,
but if the government closes its doors
to foreigners,
those banks you hire immigrants will
have it to significantly harder than
before and make no mistake.
This is not only due to brexit.
In fact,
the anti immigrant sentiment in the UK,
it's been going well beyond the borders
of the European Union.
Theresa
may discharge companies 2000 pounds per
year for each non European Union worker
they employ,
but wasting it because there's still
more,
as I said,
Theresa May and so Conservative Party
have lost a good share of the seats in
parliament as well.
Where did those seats go?
Well,
they went to the Labor policy.
A policy leader,
Jeremy Corbyn has declared war on the
backs on his election manifesto.
He already proposed things like this for
cultural UK financial transaction tax
until now.
This tax was one of the biggest
advantages that UK had over the EU.
As you might know,
Brussels has been for years debating the
possibility of having a financial
transaction tax.
This is something bankers really don't
wants and no one really wants to pay,
but if the UK parliament ends up passing
such a law,
a lot of companies will be wondering if
they still want to keep their offices in
London.
In other words,
even if the brexit negotiations ended up
being great for the UK interests,
the ad is still becoming more and more
poisonous for the UKS financial
industry,
and this explains why so many banks are
starting to think about opening offices
outside of the.
Okay.
Now the question is why are they
choosing Frankfurt?
Well,
let's have a look at that financial
capital.
On the very day after the brexit
referendum,
the race to take over London as the
global financial capital started,
for example,
in Spain,
the regional governments of Madrid
launched their own advertising campaign,
designed to attract bankers,
even the Finance Minister Luis held
personal meetings with executives from
jp Morgan and elsewhere to offer special
tax conditions in Paris.
Emmanuel macron had already announced
lower taxes for banks in order to hinder
them from London,
but I'm sorry guys,
it's really hard to beat the India.
Frankly.
Standard Charter Plc,
Nomura Holdings Inc and Di was
securities group Inc,
have all picked Germany's financial
capital for their EU base to ensure
continued access to the single market.
But if you want to stay wealthy,
which would help us and fun food city
group,
Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley are
weighing a similar decision.
But what's so special about this city?
Well,
first of all,
frank,
that already has the headquarters of the
European Central Bank as well as other
big banks like Deutsche Bank.
This means that they already have the
network effects.
We always mentioned here a visual
politic.
They have lots of other things like
startups,
law firms,
consultancy,
etc. Besides frankfurt has many business
schools with international prestige as
well as the university under the second
biggest airport in europe,
you know have in front foot like a form
that chinese companies,
we have like 800 turkish companies,
1000 companies from United States.
Only the rate of the english companies
is quite little.
But this will change from my point of
view automatically.
If this was not enough,
70 percent of the german population
speak english fluently.
This means those british banks can send
their managers to Frankfurt old
international meetings and even hire
locals without having to worry about
language.
If you think this is not important,
good luck trying to find the same setup
and France were only 39 percent of the
population speaks.
Shakespeare's language,
not to mention Spain,
where this percentage is lower than 25
percent.
Hold on a minute because there is still
more,
as I said in a previous video,
Germany is a d at centralized country.
This means regional governments and
trade unions have way more autonomy here
than they have in any other country.
Thanks to this political architecture,
the region of hessen where frankfurt is.
Locators can offer things like this.
Labor laws make it difficult to fire
people.
Frankfurt had initially proposed a
change in labor laws that would either
exempt bankers or high income earners
more generally from the rules.
Okay.
Now let's think about something else.
If you have a bank guns,
he wants to set up your offices
somewhere.
What is the first thing you will need?
Well,
that would be a building.
You need a physical place where you can
put your offices.
Well in this regard,
frankfurt is better suited than anywhere
else you see.
After world war two,
frankfurt,
it was totally destroyed and they had to
rebuild it almost nothing and other
german cities,
urban laws for the building of
skyscrapers in order to maintain the
uniform,
more traditional skyline,
but not in frankfurt.
Here you can make buildings as high as
you want.
This explains why despite a population
of less than 1 million inhabitants,
frankfurt looks like a big metropolis.
Further,
Germany asked one of the cheapest real
estate markets in all of europe.
Despite the high salaries,
houses,
rents square meters are half the price
of paris and a fraction of the cost of
london.
Okay?
Okay.
But now I know what you're thinking.
I mean,
come on simon.
What about corporate taxes and this is
the most important thing of all.
Well yeah,
I know Germany has a corporate tax that
in some cases reaches 30 percent by
comparison.
The uk is at 20 and you're absolutely
right,
but the devil here,
it's really in the details.
Do you ever.
How I said the gemini is highly
decentralized.
Well,
this applies to corporate tax to in this
country,
corporate tax.
It's divided into two parts and national
and a regional one.
This means that the federal government's
gets only 15 percent of the tax.
The rest depends on the
region.
This means technically the state of
hessen where frankfurt is really has the
ability to reduce this tax a lot and of
course doing this mice and more and more
british bankers that I'm finally,
if none of this was enough of you,
here comes the big finale,
the financial transaction tax.
This was the tax bill you mentioned
before.
That scares away so many bankers.
That tax,
at least in europe,
has about as many loopholes as possible.
There are so many exceptions on this tax
that Even its biggest supporter,
the german finance minister had this to
say humanist swiss cheese needs more
than holes or has to be something in
between them.
Otherwise it's just a hole,
not a swiss cheese.
Wolfgang schauble.
So now we have a question for you.
Imagine you are the manager of one of
these london banks.
What would you do?
Would you remain in london or perhaps
would you move your offices to
frankfurt?
Well,
do let us know in the comments below.
Meanwhile,
if you want to learn more about how
london became such financial powerhouse,
do you click on this other video?
Also remember to visit reconsider
media.com,
the podcast that provided the vocals in
this video that are not mine,
and don't forget as we published brand
new videos every monday and every
thursday,
so hit that subscribe button and you
will not miss any post.
And if you liked this video,
give us a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear more
of my lovely voice,
don't forget to checkout reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com.
We consider as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your abuse by
providing context,
but we don't do the thinking for them.